I've seen some who oppose this
impeachment airily dismiss it yeah the
president may have behaved badly on that
call with Ukraine but it's not Impe
chable let's wait till the election to
hash it all out okay except that's not
how this is going to go down it looks
like this will end up with a trial in
the Senate and as we move towards that I
want anyone who watches this show to be
well informed about the details about
the actual evidence not the talking
points the evidence now we had a lot of
new evidence this week and I want to
take you through it here's what hasn't
changed though this week we had new
confirmation from an old friend of the
real motivation for all this he knows
he's an illegitimate president he knows
he's an illegitimate president he knows
that he's an illegitimate president
they've been wanting to get Trump since
2016 they want to remove this
democratically elected president by non
democratic means regardless of the
evidence so helpful of Hillary to
confirm that this week and so much for
their pious lectures on democracy and
the rule of law last Sunday we went
through the impeachment charges inviting
foreign meddling and a quid pro quo of
military aid the foreign meddling claim
is a joke it happens every day in
Washington through foreign government
lobbying the Democrats are up to their
necks in foreign meddling Nancy Pelosi
took money from Ukraine lobbyists Chuck
Schumer took money from Saudi Arabia and
Mexico these sanctimonious charlatans on
a high horse over foreign interference
in our democracy have no problem with it
when it's donations to their campaigns
and jobs for their relatives when it's
asking Ukraine for dirt on Trump as
Democrat senators did last year and of
course when it's funding a dossier to
bring Trump down in any case elected
leaders always wear their government hat
and that of a politician every
conversation every meeting they're
thinking about the politics the idea
that Donald Trump committed an abuse of
power by bringing politics into a
foreign relationship is a joke they all
do it Trump is just more open about it I
saw it myself with President Obama and
David Cameron and when the bush campaign
asked British conservatives for dirt on
Bill Clinton today the impeachment
fanatics recite the mantra dirt on a
political rival but with Ukraine and
Biden it's not just any rival and it's
not just any dirt if President Trump was
asking the Ukrainians to look for
weather I don't know Andrew yang I was
back paid to some Ukrainian computer
scientist who worked on one of his
startups that would be different but the
charge here and we will lay it out for
you in detail in tonight's swamp watch
is that a former vice president and his
family acted corruptly in another
country while in office of course that
should be investigated and there's
nothing wrong with asking that country
to help the reason the Democrats in the
ruling class are so up in arms about him
is that it's exposing a central feature
of their swampy business model what's
not okay is using government policy and
taxpayer dollars to push for an
investigation if the motivation is
purely political the only really serious
charge here is that President Trump did
that by withholding military aid to
Ukraine unless they promised to
investigate Biden and that he did it for
purely political ends last week I told
you there were three reasons to reject
that argument one Trump is a well-known
aid skeptic to Senator Rob Portman
backed up the president's account and
three according to the New York Times
the Ukrainians didn't know the aide was
held up until a month after that now
famous phone call how can there be a
quid pro quo when one side didn't know
about the quo I said well we've learned
more about it this week from senior
diplomats text messages it turns out
that the aid holdup was seen by some US
officials as part of a purely political
quid pro quo here's bill Taylor the
acting ambassador to Ukraine as I said
on the phone I think it's crazy to
withhold security assistance for help
with a political campaign the Democrats
think that's their smoking gun but the
reply from the US ambassador to the EU
was this bill I believe you are
incorrect about president Trump's
intentions the president has been
crystal clear no quid pro quos of any
kind
now look I'm just being honest with you
here
those texts on their own without context
shook my faith in the White House
position and of course the Trump hating
media were all over it the New York
Times plastered the texts across their
front page yesterday with dramatic
yellow highlights it left me wanting to
know two things were the Ukrainians told
that the military aid was being held up
on us they investigated Biden and what
was the intention to investigate Biden
on the grounds of vice presidential
corruption or because he was a political
rival now as luck would have it we got
more evidence on exactly those points
the text messages were given to Congress
by Kurt Volker our special envoy to
Ukraine he also gave them an 11-page
witness statement some commentators
called that statement devastating for
the president pointing to the fact that
Volcker debunks claims by Rudy Giuliani
and the president about Ukraine's role
in 2016 and Joe Biden's role in Ukraine
that is perfectly true but it's not the
whole story in fact it's not even the
main story Volcker statement is indeed
devastating but not for the president if
you read the whole thing rather than
cherry-pick the anti-trump bits the
statement is devastating for the
Democrats it's devastating to the case
for impeachment it pretty much
exonerates the president on the main
impeachment charges kurt volker has been
involved in every aspect of this story
dealing face to face with all the key
players all along president trump
president solinsky's olenska's advisor
Rudy Giuliani Volk has been described by
Trump critics as an honest broker listen
to his actual evidence on page three he
says at no time was I aware of or took
part in an effort to urge Ukraine to
investigate former Vice President Biden
as you will see from the extensive text
messages I am providing which convey a
sense of real-time dialogue with several
different actors Vice President Biden
was never a topic of discussion on page
six talking about President Trump
delaying a meeting with zalenski a delay
that based on the texts alone the media
cite as evidence of Trump pressuring
Ukraine to investigate by
volker says but I believed that the
president's long-held negative view
toward Ukraine was causing hesitation in
actually scheduling the meeting nothing
to do with investigating Biden just
president Trump's concerns over Ukraine
corruption exactly as he's been saying
on page seven Volcker reports on a
meeting he arranged between President
zelinsky's advisor and Rudy Giuliani
after they met both mayor Giuliani and
mr. Yermak called me to give me their
impressions both were positive neither
said anything about Vice President Biden
based just on the text the Democrats and
their media allies have zeroed in on
talk of a statement that the u.s. side
wanted the Ukrainians to make again this
is cited as evidence of pressure to
investigate Biden but on page eight of
his evidence Volcker says on August the
16th mr. uremic shared a draft with me
which I thought looked perfectly
reasonable it did not mention Purisima
or 2016 elections but was generic I
conveyed this draft to ambassador song
lund who agreed it was an excellent
statement we had a further conversation
with mayor Giuliani who said that in his
view this statement should include
specific reference to BER yzma and 2016
again there was no mention of Vice
President Biden in these conversations
on to the most serious charge against
the president that there was a quid pro
quo on military aid here's what Kurt
Volker says on page 9 of his statement
the issue of a hold placed on security
assistance to Ukraine also came up
during this same time I was connecting
mr. uremic and Mayor Giuliani I did not
perceive these issues to be linked in
any way got that no link between the
Giuliani investigation agenda and the
aid and then finally on page 10 what
Volcker was told at the time about the
president's phone call by people who
were actually on the call I received a
general readout via our show je and my
own State Department star phone as well
as from mr. Urich all said it was a good
congratulatory call that they discussed
the importance of fighting corruption
and promoting reform in Ukraine and the
president from reiterated his invitation
to president zalenski to visit the White
House six times in an L
eleven page statement the special envoy
to Ukraine the man at the center of all
this described even by Trump critics as
an honest broker six times he said that
he saw no evidence of efforts to
investigate Biden as a political rival
or to link that to aid in a quid pro quo
the fact that no one literally no one as
far as I'm aware has reported this just
shows you how committed the media are to
their anti Trump narrative it is
astonishing
these people are deliberately misleading
you their contempt for Trump has
destroyed their professional judgment in
a week when we saw the unemployment rate
again hit a 50-year low we're reminded
why Americans chose Donald Trump jobs
and dignity after decades of stagnation
and disrespect immigration brought under
control after decades of open borders
China confronted after decades of
sellout and surrender the Democrats
obsession with scandal is out of touch
and decadent people want substance not
scandal we'll explain you the
impeachment errors evidence for as long
as this goes on but for God's sake can
the Democrats please just get a grip end
this fast and focus on helping Americans
have a better life now please make sure
you share this this detailed setting out
of the evidence far and wide we'll post
it on social media and please follow us
at Steve Hilton X and at next Rev fnc